developers have been creating instant
apps for over a year now enabling users
to enjoy their apps by simply tapping a
link or pressing a button in the Play
Store instead of installing the entire
app but we didn't want to stop there
games are a big part of the user
experience on phones for this reason
we've extended the instant app
technology to games welcome to Google
Play instant where apps and games can be
played instantly you might have seen the
ux best practices for instant apps that
we published last year on the Android
developers channel if you haven't yet
that worth checking out the link is in
the video description below don't worry
I'll be here when you come back but
since games are a little different than
apps I'd like to talk a bit about the
user experience specifically for games
on Google Play Instant there are many
different ways that users can access a
game without installing it users may be
coming from an add a link on a website a
message from a friend the play games app
Google search results or the try Now
button on the Play Store consider what
you want your gaming experience on
Google Play Instant to accomplish do you
want it to be a standalone game that is
completely instant or can you make the
first level of your game available to be
accessed instantly allowing users to try
out your game some developers have
created this sort of companion to their
existing games this experience creates
excitement with your gamers by showing
off the most exciting parts of a game
before installation there are plenty of
exciting options to choose from think
about which route you want to take and
be deliberate when building out your
instant experience in doing so you'll
increase your reach by providing value
to your gamers we've created a new
loading UI for launching games from
Google Play instant we think it's much
more appropriate for a gaming experience
and users have been telling us that they
love it it sometimes takes a little
longer to launch a game than it is to
launch an app so it was important for us
to keep users entertained while a game
is loading to avoid users abandoning
your experience try to get them into the
gameplay as
as possible if it is necessary to show
an additional loading stream in the game
try to shorten it as much as possible
you can load in additional parts of your
game during runtime using the Google
Play Quora library when prompting users
to install your game or to pre-register
show a button in your UI that uses the
words install or pre-register in games
is usually better to not just rely on
the download or install I can alone you
can choose to show the prompt
permanently in your UI between levels or
as part of the main menu whether you
choose only one of these options or all
of them make sure that your users can
have a great experience even without
installing your game your instant
experience shouldn't be reduced to an ad
banner it is important to save your
users progress when they play your game
after installing it in particular their
achievements and their purchases must
not go missing after they've decided to
install your game you can use the cookie
and storage API to do this people will
want to keep their magic battle acts
that they fought so hard for against
those ugly goblins in that dungeon as it
is possible to access games on Google
Play instant by simply clicking a link
some users will access temps are in
dipper Disney or unintentionally for
those users it is important to have a
way back out of the game if they choose
to leave do not disable the Android back
button at the bottom of the screen it is
fine to show warning when it is pressed
to alert users they're about to exit the
game but it is good practice not to
disrupt established navigational
patterns Google Play Instant is a
fantastic way for users to share their
gaming experience for friends and let
them try it out themselves in your game
make it easy for users to invite others
to join them players are much more
likely to join if they're not only
invited by someone they know but also
get to try out the experience before
they commit to purchasing purchasing it
themselves to recap when designing a
user experience for your game on Google
Play Instant consider the right entry
points and use cases for your game
remove any unnecessary latency and let
your users experience the game as
quickly as possible think about the
right moment in your experience to
prompt for installation and
pre-registration make sure your users
maintain their progress after installing
the game don't disable the Android back
button and provide a way for users to
share a game with others we believe that
games on Google Play Instant are a great
way to remove friction for your users we
can wait to see what you will build with
it you can find everything I talked
about here and much more on cheeto co /
instant apps also check out our
recommendations for building a good user
experience in your instant apps you can
find the link in the description below
thanks for watching
[Music]